Welcome to the
Man of Recaps, this is Reacher season one.
Meet Jack Reacher, an absolute
giant of a man.
He's just come to Georgia
for some peach pie,
but he's rudely interrupted
by being arrested.
The Harvard-educated tweed-wearing Detective
Finlay fills him in,
there was a murder late last night.
Reacher is suspect number one
because he's a mysterious drifter
with no home address or possessions.
But it's soon obvious Reacher's innocent, he’s a retired war hero
who just came to town
because he loves blues music.
In fact Reacher almost solves
the case immediately,
he was a military investigator who's got
Sherlock-Holmes-like powers of deduction.
The victim had a phone number
in his pocket, which leads them to this banker guy,
and when he sees a mysterious car watching him,
he confesses to the murder,
even though he obviously didn't do it.
Now Reacher's not free till his alibi clears,
so Finlay
forces him to help the investigation.
He and the banker spend the night in jail,
where he hopes
the banker will tell Reacher the truth.
But whatever he's involved in
is real serious,
as some inmates
were already hired to kill him.
So Richard gives them
to the count of three.
“One--” oh! Attacks immediately!
That's his whole fighting strategy,
never hesitate.
Strike first, strike hard, Cobra Kai.
Now that Reacher's alibi cleared,
he’s picked up from jail by the hot cop Roscoe.
He tells her about his wandering lifestyle,
he's not a “vagrant,” he’s a “hobo.”
And he enjoys having no possessions,
whenever he needs to change a shirt, he just buys a new one.
So Reacher's planning to mosey on,
until he learns he knows the victim...
It is his brother Joe!
And now the case gets bigger when the chief of police is murdered,
brutally nailed to the wall.
Now they realize
there's a vast conspiracy,
all the other cops are probably dirty,
Reacher's the only one they can trust.
First off, banker guy disappeared,
they got to protect his family,
So Finlay calls in his FBI friend
who babysits them for the season.
Their top suspect is Mr. Kleiner, the rich guy in town,
who seems real good and is obviously bad.
Especially because his son, K.J., has been threatening Reacher,
even though Reacher could crush his head with one hand.
So they interview Kleiner
but can't find anything,
the only thing
suspicious is all the cow feed he ordered,
“A hell of a lot of cow feed”
for not that many cows.
So Reacher keeps investigating,
which mostly entails beating people up.
He starts hanging out with Officer Roscoe,
who hooks him up with her uncle's gun,
an absolutely massive Desert Eagle.
When the bad guys break into her house
she and Reacher go hide in a motel,
where they start to fall in love,
and pretty soon... get it on!
The case keeps getting more complex,
what are professional Venezuelan hitmen doing in this small Georgia town?
So Reacher gets help from his old friend
Neagley,
who was in his Special Investigators
unit back in the military.
Now somehow
related is the river pollution,
and when a dirty cop captures them, Reacher and Neagley get to see the river real close up.
And now Reacher has to change his shirt
again.
Now Reacher’s brother Joe worked for the Secret Service,
and when they talk
to his coworker-slash-girlfriend,
they learn
he was investigating counterfeiting.
She comes to town to give them the files,
but no! The bad guys kill her too.
In New York Reacher talks
to the counterfeiting expert,
who tells him
it's the paper that you just can't fake.
But the bad guys have goons here too, so Reacher kills this guy with his necktie,
then has to change his shirt again.
So it's starting to come together: Mr. Kleiner is running a vast
counterfeiting network
where they're shipping
fake money down to Venezuela.
But when Finlay goes to his office
to find evidence,
Oh! Mr. Kleiner was already killed! He wasn’t the top dog.
So Reacher lays a trap
by telling one of the corrupt cops where he’s going to be,
then he goes into commando mode,
so when the hit squad comes for him, Reacher's doing the hitting.
But during the fight
Reacher got knocked into the pool,
and now his notepaper is all faded.
And that's the final puzzle piece,
how are they getting the money paper?
They're just using one dollar bills!
Washing the ink off,
then reprinting them as hundreds.
And that's what all the cattle feed was
for, using it to dry the paper.
But the bad guys are one step ahead,
because Finlay's FBI friend was in on it the whole time!
And it's Kleiner Jr who killed his dad
and took over the operation,
because he's a little psychopath.
But they're not killing Reacher yet, they need his help
to find the banker guy, who they didn't kill, he’s in hiding.
But Reacher sneakily grabs
a fork to pop the tire,
then in the trunk, grabs a gun and gets away.
Then the time for subtlety is over,
as Reacher and friends
attack the warehouse
and go in guns blazing!
In the final showdown with K.J.,
he's distracted
monologuing about hunting a rhinoceros.
So Reacher just grabs
this punk, throws him in the fire!
Avenges his brother, and the day is saved.
Now Reacher
and Roscoe have fallen in love,
but he can't stick around, he's
got to keep wandering.
And she's like “Yeah, I figured. This
kind of seems like a James Bond thing...”
“where you have a new hot
girlfriend every season.”
So Reacher finally gets his peach pie,
then leaves town for his next adventure.
And that's
where Reacher season one comes to an end.
If you liked this recap, hit that subscribe button,
for more of the best recaps of TV and movies.